le département de la réunion aux côtés
des réunionnais être accueillis par un
accueillant familial
l'accueil familial est une solution
intermédiaire entre le maintien à
domicile
l'hébergement l'établissement il permet
à une personne âgée et ou adultes
porteuses d'un handicap d'être
accueillis chez un m'accueillant
familiale à qui s'adresse-t-il aux
personnes âgées qui ne peuvent plus se
maintenir à leur domicile sans pour
autant vouloir vivre en collectivité
aux personnes adultes en situation de
handicap qui ne disposent pas de
l'autonomie suffisante pour vivre de
façon indépendante
comment
pour faire une demande afin d'être
accueillis rapprochez vous du service du
département de votre secteur de
résidence au 02 62 28 98 28 pour le
secteur nord 02 62 50 20 00 pour le
secteur s 02 62 55 47 55 pour le secteur
ouest et 02 62 96 90 00 pour le secteur
suite
pour tous renseignements rendez vous sur
www.cc 9 7 4 points est faire rubrique
social accueil familial
cette formule originale qui met fin à
l'isolément d'un public vulnérable
constitue une priorité du conseil
départemental